the net is vast and infinite and losing
its damn mind so the whole ghost in the
shell Scarlett Johansson casting thing
this wasn't something that I thought I
was going to do a video because I
actually gave my initial thoughts on the
thing when she was first cast in the
role over a year ago where was
everybody's outrage then forget that
moving on although i did a video at the
time i didn't really talk too much about
the race issue because honestly it
didn't occur to me this was a US
production backed by a u.s. major
Hollywood studio I always kind of
assumed they were going to cast her
white but once the first image actually
hit became visually clear to everybody
now there has been a whole lot of back
and forth with people talking about
whitewashing how is completely wrong
people defending it in the specific
instance because of story or character
based reasons and what I'm not going to
do in this video is I'm not going to
address a lot of these specific pros or
cons in favor or against the casting of
Scarlett Johansson in what is originally
a Japanese character I'm going to talk a
bit more in broad strokes I'm gonna
start with the broadest strokes to lay
some foundation so we can move on in
discussion and i wanna i do want to
start by debunking one of the major
arguments that happens cuz i don't want
to have to keep dealing with it and
that's one of the arguments from people
who would be defending the casting of
someone like Scarlett Johansson in a
role like this and many people will
point to instances of traditionally
white characters being recast as
different ethnicities and go well why is
that okay but casting this character
with Scarlett Johansson is not okay you
know all things being equal it why is
that any different it should either
always be okay to recast race or it
should never be okay to recast race you
shouldn't be selective like this that's
the argument but it doesn't work because
there was a phrase I used very
intentionally and that was the phrase
all things being equal because if all
things were equal that argument be
completely valid in strict fairness that
should be no different but the thing is
all things aren't equal that's not the
world that we live in and the vast
majority of major roles in blockbuster
films go
white actors disproportionately so so
we're not starting from an even playing
field and that argument that well if you
cast a white character as black or
anything else and that's fine but this
isn't bad argument only works if we're
on a level playing field or something
close to it and we're just not so we're
going to set that aside and move on so
the question now becomes is it ever
appropriate to cast a traditionally
ethnic whether it be Asian or black or
whatever character with a white actor
for the film version and there are many
people who make the argument no it is
never appropriate I actually don't quite
land there even though I recognize the
the unfairness in terms of what roles
are going disproportionately to what
group of actors who look a certain way
because there's a certain amount of
context that you need to give certain
interpretations that I think just the
black and white no you can never do it
just overlooks and I'm going to cite a
couple specific examples and I'm going
to start with the departed now this was
the movie that Martin Scorsese finally
won his directing Oscar for now what you
may or may not know is that this was
actually a remake the original was a
Japanese film called infernal affairs
now that original film was set in Tokyo
and it dealt with the Yakuza but it was
that same basic plot of the Yakuza have
a mole in the police department the
police department have them all in the
Yakuza and because it's set in Tokyo
dealing with the our Kuzon it's very
steeped in Japanese culture and history
and all the rest of it now when Martin
Scorsese and his team made their version
it was moved to Boston and dealt with
the Irish mob so were they racist for
changing that well no they took the
bones and the structure and the plot and
then moved it to a location that they
were familiar with and were comfortable
telling a story within a more recent I
think even more appropriate example
would be the film edge of tomorrow which
some people know as lived I repeat now
that was originally a japanese light
novel called all you need is kill which
again set in japan japanese characters
when they made the film version it was
reset in europe so and then they cast
american and british actors and again
nobody really called foul because this
was a reinterpretation this was
taking the basic concept and plot but
doing it from a perspective that was no
longer a Japanese perspective so from
the ground up it was just coming at it
from a different angle in that different
angle allowed for a change in the
ethnicity of what the original
characters were so where does ghost in
the shell land in all this well here's
the thing what a lot of people have been
failing to note is that even though the
character that Scarlett Johansson is
playing any fan of ghost in the shell
whether a fan of the manga the anime
whatever they know that the main
character is major motoko kusanagi now
here's the thing none of the official
press release information from
dreamworks or paramount which of the two
studios involved in this have actually
named her as motor co Kusanagi they
refer to her only as the major I'm
personally not surprised at this I
called this a year ago when she was
first cast they were just going to refer
to her as the major and leave it at that
and as for the rest of the cast it's
very much ethnically mixed and we don't
know how many of the characters are
going to retain their original Japanese
names the only one that we know for
certain is is going to be chief Aramaki
being played by takeshi kitano who is in
fact a japanese actor so it's looking
like they're doing that approach that I
talked about they're taking it and
moving it somewhere else and changing
the setting and that allows them for
this free casting so that should end the
argument right well here's the rub let's
look at this picture again that look is
the look very specifically of Motor Co
Kusanagi that color palette is the color
palette of the classic 90s anime film
version of this story this film isn't
just taking the bare-bones concept
Andrea propriate in it into something
new it's treading on the iconography and
it's very much absorbing all of the
things from earlier versions and from
the original manga and its end it Keith
it's keeping the name its banking on all
of this stuff that is originating from
its Japanese source material and in
doing so it kind of loses credibility in
terms of that while we're moving into
another culture argument they're not
changing it to represent a different
culture the way that the departed did or
edge of tomorrow did and that
muddies the waters a little bit now
where does that mean this lands
ultimately honestly i would say kind of
in the middle what i mean when i say
that is this is ultimately an example of
what many are calling whitewashing i
feel that term is a little overly harsh
in the specific instance but it does
serve as an example of that you're
taking a Japanese character and
maintaining the Japanese story and even
some of the Japanese supporting
characters around her but you've changed
that to accommodate a white actor but at
the same time it is maintaining a very
culturally diverse cast and given a lot
of the elements of the story in terms of
cybernetic bodies and everything else
there is a narrative argument to be made
that could I'm not going to say
necessarily prove this casting correct
but you can justify it what I say just
if I mean from a strictly narrative
perspective because if you're going to
look at it from a cultural stance not
it's much harder to justify in it is a
problem and I think that's where people
rightly have a certain amount of anger
because this is yet another example of
something that has been an ongoing issue
the thing is that people are getting
have gotten very hung up on this
specific example is it an example of
whitewashing and casting yes honestly it
is is it the strongest example of it
well we're having this discussion in the
same year in which a movie called gods
of Egypt start an Australian a dane and
a Scotsman so no this is not the best
example but it is another example to
illustrate an overall pattern a systemic
issue in which actors of non-white
ethnicities are simply not given the
opportunity to grow and become stars and
then it becomes a self-perpetuating
cycle because Hollywood says well we
have to cast Scarlett Johansson because
she's a box-office strong there's no big
name Asian female box-office drawers but
they're never giving them the rules to
let them become box-office drawers and
it just goes round and round around so I
think what we have to a certain extent
in how big the conversation has gotten
around a specific movie is a little bit
of case of missing the forest for the
trees it is absolutely an example and
it's one more instance 2.2 along with
things like gods of Egypt or Exodus or
any of
other examples but the what gives it
weight is the number of instances this
specific instance I don't actually think
makes the best case add it to the pile
certainly but you need to make the
bigger case as opposed to get hung up
into the arguments as to whether or not
this specific instance is the most
egregious I think that's where
unfortunately conversation has got
installed what should have happened is
the casting of Scarlett Johansson should
have kick-started a bigger conversation
but unfortunately what's happened
instead is the people have said this is
an example of what we're talking about
and other people will come back no it's
not it's fine for them to do this
because of X and then the first site has
to refute that argument and then it gets
refuted again and we're just we're never
moving past this one movie and when we
can't move past the specific example
that's when the problem just never gets
fixed and the one thing that I think is
worth just mentioning at the end of this
is Japan itself by and large doesn't
seem to care because their reaction was
kind of what I said at the beginning
which was Hollywood's making it we
always assumed it was gonna be a white
person cast now does the fact that the
country of origin is not outraged mean
that nobody should be outraging you have
no right to your outrage no of course
not because the outrage isn't really
about this specific movie it's about the
Hollywood System and systemic issues
that are built in to who gets an
opportunity to lead a movie and who
doesn't and it's an American problem
it's not a problem with this specific
film although this specific film can be
used as an example of the bigger issue
so ultimately is this a bit of a cop-out
answer huh maybe it is so if you are
want to call me out as just towing the
middle line and refusing to take a stand
out you know what you tell me what your
stance is whatever it is drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it let's try and have a civil
discussion please that's what I hope to
get out of all this I'm trying to weigh
all sides and keep it civil so I mean
whatever your feelings are just be
respectful so let's have a nice
conversation you can follow me on
twitter at council of geeks check out
the council of geeks podcast at stitcher
and on iTunes you can email me council
geeks @ gmail.com and until next time
this council is
earned